the true story of Pocahontas the other
side of history with all we know about
Pocahontas how much is fact how much is
fiction well that's an interesting
question now from the Mattapan I pouches
perspective much of what's been in
mainstream America has been not ESDA
diction it's been alleged so let's start
with the fact what is fact about
Pocahontas the well fact is she was
powered cheap Alton Wallace Silica's
favorite daughter fact is she she did
marry a paladin warrior she had a child
by this palace and warrior and she was
captured by Captain Argyll in 1613
captured
kidnapped kidnapped because there was a
ransom it was more than simply abduction
it was an actual ransom her father
offered to pay that ransom
captain Argyll refused to accept it took
her Jamestown dr. Linwood little bear
Costello
why was Pocahontas kidnapped his
kidnapped because of the fact if they
needed someone to represent feminine and
I thinking
who needed someone to represent them in
anything within you investment and with
the witness ricotta colony right what
did they have to do with her kidnapping
they basically the they funded the money
to bring the people over and change the
people Jeff and John Smith went home and
the mothers came over and when the new
group got over and took charge of the
colony then that's when the day begins
we took the baby being delivered to the
back they input the back of the grow and
the first thing they wanted to do is get
the approval again from the
from England because of the fact that
the English church and the cambrian
business had wanted to be a people here
arm that would describe them really
Angela Daniel silver star
what role did Pocahontas played then
with the Virginia investment company
closer what was her purpose
well she brought and a piece but the
palace and people under paladin
leadership her father had already
offered to being muscala
if they were to live as how it's in
English under their rules but the
English did not want to live under the
power to rule so when they captured her
because she was his favorite daughter
they were banking that he would not
attack them and that's what and he did
not and so it did create a piece there
was a lot of real solitude
how old is Pocahontas when she was
kidnapped she's kidnapped around 14
years old 14 years old and did she want
to marry John Wall
no she really didn't she had a husband
it's Road and this was basically let me
put another spin to you on the
Pocahontas catcher
yes and that is that Ceylon tea was
captured basically they were looking for
hers and really he was trying to hide
with the husband nothing from the
Potomac River by the Peshwa compelled
the Potter 1hr appellant had to say
and there that the founder and I
captured her and took her back and it
sort of just the way it happened we can
very easily if they were capturing her
full of purpose that purpose is
fulfilled to marriage to John wrong
because he was part of the John Ross
himself was a agent visit man some of
the daily investment and what role did
Captain John Smith playing all this
well he was the
she palettes and waha Seneca the
warriors the palates and warriors
captured him and they took in the
capital to kick outs and why Seneca and
who was his father right okay and and T
Houghton offers Captain John Smith to be
a sub seen over there was colonists to
be aware was so that's where he fits in
they accordance from the palette ins
perspective John Smith was to be a sub
chief so she would have looked at him as
a person of Honor within her society
what about the story that Pocahontas
saved his life well if you're making
somebody a chief why would you want to
be tied to kill them and that's even in
the written documents apparent John
Smith himself like Chief Powhatan offers
the colonists lands live lon
he's but he's making him a part of a
chief and he said I'll let you go in
four days what she did but if you're
making somebody a chief you're not going
to try to kill them
that's within itself proof of the fact
that he was not a part of the situation
that's right he was infecting but they
needed him first initially it could be
to make the total settlement in contact
because he was the most widely
experienced one in England for that job
and after they felt the accomplices but
had a way of getting him back
dr. Linwood little bear customer you
write that this is amol history
throughout her story of Pocahontas what
do you mean by oral history
our own histamine that's been handed
down and it's not just been handed down
that I like you tell a story ending it
down from under father and grandfather
it was talked we had what's called ki
across a priest of the Powhatan nation
and they hid in the mouth and I Drive
and the and the monkey tribe would
interface that the payment English at
the time in the settlement and so
therefore this is that and so basically
they took took the histories and and
they decided on the most important phase
of the history to keep earthly history
of this services to the palate and
nation was the history why do you think
the story of Pocahontas has been taught
over and over again is relate use goals
and movies etc
well there is a fill goodness to it how
the Indian matin is the one that falls
in love with the the incoming people and
their ways are better than her
traditional ways and it makes you it
makes the colonial perspective seem
legitimate because she after all
realized this was a good thing happening
there is that sort of the underlining
themes that run under the surface
alludes where you with that do you agree
with that pieces
from the palliative perspective
certainly not she would have been a for
one thing she would have been thinking
pretty much like any other palates in
person would have at that time second of
all it was her father that offered the
Peace of the colonists being a political
leadership at the time that the colonist
arrived she was only 10 years old in
1607 she didn't have the agency to do
the things that she was claimed to be of
God so what is the magnitude of that the
palette of people really want to be
allies and friends with the colonists
are supposed to enemies he was looking
at having someone basically under his
authority we're talking about the nation
there that could contained other sub
Chiefs another tribe tribe is like a
state in the United States if it's some
states have one paramount chief and the
others chief of the beach' each state
would be the government
that would be the recipe how far did
Chief Powhatan and his tribe lived from
Jamestown
Chief Powhatan lived about nine months
and days but you have to cross a river
that's about to yeah well that's a very
amount of it actually not to danger but
the York River Hank and that used to be
the Pamunkey River they changed it to
the ark so the days of yore
Pocahontas want to go to England
she at the time she was fitting in she
was hoping that by going to England that
this would perform with them in going
along with them in spite of having her
own husband killed to do it that this
would give a better relationship with
the her and her father and rested the
drive she didn't really know what was
totally what was going on this out it's
going to ask does she have any idea why
she was being taken back according to
the medicine I oral history it wasn't
till after she got there that she
realized the magnitude of what was
happening and what was happened that she
was being used as a PR floyd to pour the
call of the colonists that were in her
homeland pursuits through the english
people in the crown that everything was
fine and happy and everybody was getting
along with each other in the column how
long was she there we see the people in
the in england did the Church of England
and the king of canning was at the time
and so you had those people have wanted
were interested in the Chiefs daughter
to her seeing her at number one and but
they wanted they wanted to be sure that
they were that we were not being treated
wrongly so they had to gesture prepare
properly to meet them and dress her up
and make it look like she was to them to
that everything was hunky-dory here she
is knowing you it seems ankle sides
yes gazenga side and not just his anger
side but but that to choose the daughter
of the king of this side of the waters
and that she was she did they did at the
base that be they could be presentable
to the kid you did purpose of that was
not so much that she was angry sizes is
that they because they saw that they
were treating her they were treating her
well there's a big big attitude between
the same thing as all the rest was it a
successful strategy to raise money for
the Virginians a very successful
and also well with this they had a
chance to see it they came over looking
for gold and they didn't find gold they
had to find something that the board's
calumny and of course the dunya
investment company had to get their
money back some way so their son John
Ross over to explore tobacco and since
the Spaniard route had taken tobacco
from South Americans was going wild over
there in Europe and so surely enough
under the capture David they had taken
made use of that to learn how to go to
back on how to cure tobacco and so while
we helping because of really cheap
over the king geared with Saranac Chiefs
daughter the game
is she ever return message oh no how old
was she when she died
just 20 about 21 one man would each
entire well of course the oral Mallesons
Madame's Nile but traditions she was
harder let me give you a little
background behind that which is
different by poison but just me we know
we know that order the captain of the
ship and John Ross why
didn't wanted to come back did they were
through which had gotten accomplished
what they said what they had intended to
do to appease the hammering run in the
church so they're really NASA
co-enrolled with the tobacco and also
they were see keep in mind that there
there is only open land to have Rosetta
that was cleared by the tribe to go to
the feed to back along and while they're
over there they tested to tobacco and
they had
did put it into the rival then with the
standard tobacco smoking into it
how did you get to this to write this
problem how did the two of you get
together to write this book where did
you collect this oral history darryl
history as I told you came from the
Kiros I'm a defendant of the care pros
the care person the hid in the mouth and
I tried be hidden the upper echelon of
the tribe and soon came the chief
subscribe so in systematic way of
maintaining and knowledge through an all
trendy and different and what we did was
basically they sacrificed the lives that
the people did willingly of the other
force divisions the virtual medicine on
the governmental and did decide the
history of the most important party and
so that's if they hid they could be
people that were keeping the history of
those four specialties that's one they
kept
dr. crustal Oh what is your background
our Mattapan dye and the pendant of the
gear grows and according to your
biography here you're the first Virginia
Indian to graduate from Medical School
correct
no yes from medical school but I was the
first Virginia first American to be
graduate from medical through all in
Virginia in the United States and the
first one to graduate from college
hi I'm Angela Daniel Silverstar what is
your background
well I got my bachelor's at the
University of Virginia an anthropology
and I'm working on my PhD at the College
of William and Mary and originally might
be certain anthropology originally my
dissertation was to be centered on the
mattify oral tradition so that's what we
we were working together to document the
man up and I oral tradition and while we
were in that process I had another
project with my advisor of asking and
doing a survey for in the Native
community and one of the questions was
what do you think about how the story of
Pocahontas is taught in the school
system and the native people kept saying
tell the true story of Pocahontas so I
went back to Lin little bear said why
don't we do this
straightforward account of the mana by
that much how its obverse know what
happened with Hana is always Pocahontas
talking schools today in Virginia did
she say that to talk to tell you
something
yeah John Smith was really comes back to
England what they didn't want him there
really
things are changing over to where they
were then changing from looking from
droves looking for another type of role
published by fulcrum the true story of
Pocahontas the other side of the story
by dr. Linwood little bear Costello and
Angela Daniel Silva stock